build draft algorithms
hi thanks for the kind description
um
and this is a list of my affiliations
past and future I'm very excited to be
here as a research fellow this semester
hopefully you can get to talk to a lot
of you about very interesting problems
um and today I'll be talking about a
practical graph algorithms specifically
focusing on uh scalability and privacy
um and when a theorist hears the word
practical often you might think about
heuristics or lower level engineering
um to make perhaps sub-optimal
algorithms perform well in practice
um while this is uh very important for a
lot of algorithm engineering this is not
the focus of my talk today so today I'll
be focusing on talking about provably
efficient algorithms so algorithms with
good theoretical guarantees but the
focus here is on models that consider uh
these modern practical challenges that
we see in practice
and also models that consider these uh
new Computing environments that we have
so what are our goals here
um our goals as uh algorithm designers
is to produce data structures or
algorithms with the best theoretical
guarantees in these models and we want
to produce these Solutions while keeping
in mind implementability so how how easy
it is to implement these algorithms in
practice
so what are some of these modern
challenges that we're considering uh one
of them is the sizes of these data sets
so I've included some of these common
data sets often people use
um
that represent graphs and the scales of
these data sets can range from hundreds
of billions of edges to up to trillions
of edges so even just reading these
graphs takes hundreds of gigabytes of
memory up to several terabytes of memory
and of course uh these graphs are
rapidly uh changing
um so you can have up to millions of
changes even per second depending on
what types of graphs you're considering
and finally with these increased
Computing resources of course you also
have stronger adversaries so what these
adversaries can do is that they can
violate the privacy of these users
and if you're talking about
decentralized networks you can have
nodes within the networks that
arbitrarily violate your distributed
protocol
so I kind of want to talk about the
central themes of my research so
um as you can tell from the uh title of
my presentation I care about going from
Theory to practice so how do we design
algorithms that can perform well also in
practice but I also want to emphasize
that it's also interesting to go the
other way so going from practice to
Theory and the questions we want to ask
here is can we obtain theoretically
efficient algorithms and models inspired
by practice so the word verb model was
inspired by practice register allocation
inspired by practice so a lot of these
classical problems that we're
considering are inspired by practice and
I claim that considering these modern
challenges we can also get algorithms
and techniques that are interesting
mathematically
and finally we want to consider these
problems that Inspire these
quote-unquote Universal Solutions and
what I mean here are is a very broad
definition for types of solutions or
classes of solutions that are good in
many different models and work for many
different adversarial situations and
problems and I'll give some examples of
these classes of solutions a bit later
on
um so now I'll go into the part of my
presentation where I'll be talking about
a lot of terms without giving precise
formal definitions for them if you're if
you're interested about any of these
Concepts please come talk to me or if
you're uh interested in making any of
your algorithms practical or if you want
to consider some of these uh problems
I've listed here also please come talk
to me
so uh to combat some of these challenges
I mentioned before
if you want to deal with um these
increasing input sizes uh you want
scalable algorithms and scalable
algorithms are algorithms that scale
gracefully to increasing input sizes by
utilizing your increasing number of
processors and Computing resources
so what I mean are models that take
advantage of Modern Hardware so Modern
Hardware nowadays usually consists of
multiple cores on a single machine so
your standard laptops these days contain
at least eight cores so these cores can
process information in parallel and read
them right from a single main memory
and the model that we generally consider
here is a shared memory word depth model
and in addition to these multiple core
machines you can also have many of them
and you can generally even rent them
from services like Google Cloud platform
or Amazon web services and with these
multiple machines you can form a
distributed Network in which these
machines communicate with each other
um via some communication protocols and
one such model that models this
distributed network is the MPC or the
massively parallel computation model
Dynamic algorithms handle dynamically
changing graphs this is a large part of
this program that we're we're focusing
on the semester
um and one thing I want to emphasize uh
in terms of dynamic algorithms is that
you can also have this batch Dynamic
model so batch Dynamic model uh batches
together multiple of these Dynamic
updates into one batch and the cool
thing about the bashtag model is that
you can combine it with a scalable model
from the previous slide to make this
scalable
finally for these stronger adversaries
you can have these adversarial models
like differential privacy is the gold
standard for protecting user privacy
um and you can also have various forms
of Byzantine resilient models to handle
Byzantine nodes in a decentralized
network
so what are some of these
characteristics that we want
um with the goals uh that I just stated
in mind
um the first characteristic for
practical algorithms that we want them
to be simple
so I know simple is kind of a taboo word
um for for some of us
um so it's okay for the com analysis to
be complicated but if you really want to
make
um these algorithms practically
implementable the algorithms themselves
should be simple
um and in addition
um let me just mention other
characteristic of algorithms that we
find to be scalable
um and these are algorithms with some
sort of local structure so that's very
broad what do I mean by local structure
um I mean algorithms graph algorithms
that proceed in some small number of
rounds where in each round uh each node
uses information from some local
neighborhood so you can just consider
the one hop local neighborhood and
that's just your adjacent Neighbors or
you can consider maybe the two hop or
three hop
and during each round each node takes
some small number of actions foreign
s that several of you in the audience
have actually looked at
um so this will be familiar to some of
you um for the rest unfortunately I
don't have enough time to give the
precise algorithms if you're interested
about any of these please come talk to
me
um so the first example is these
auction-based algorithms for bipartite
matching problems so you can consider
these algorithms to operate between a
set of bidders on one side of your graph
and a set of items on the other side and
the way we perform this matching is that
you proceed to bid on items
um
using uh your bidders on one side uh in
rounds so you have several rounds of
bidding and this process of bidding
gives you some matching
surprisingly or maybe not surprisingly
um this uh set of algorithms is very
practical and it results in a number of
results in a wide variety of of uh
models so here are some some of uh the
results in these models most of them are
quite recent actually
and another example
um of one of these uh structures is a
level data structure so a level data
structure uh partitions vertices into a
set of levels and for some models like
the dynamic model you can move the
vertices across the levels using some
predefined rules
turns out this class of structure is
also has a wide variety of applications
for a wide variety of problems so I
think a lot of a lot of the authors here
are actually in the audience and
for the
um for the solutions for these problems
you can also Implement them in a variety
of models
so those are just two examples if you
want more examples
um also please feel free to talk to me
afterwards
and one last thing I want to mention
before I conclude is that sometimes
um considering these algorithms with
local structure can actually give you
some relations between models
so one example
um of an algorithm with local structure
is what we call the set of locally
adjustable graph algorithms and we can
actually show that these graph
algorithms that fall under this locally
adjustable set of graph algorithms can
be turned into
algorithms with strong privacy
guarantees
so the specific privacy guarantees that
we care about here
um is this local model of privacy
um where you don't have a central
curator and each node protects the
privacy of its own adjacency list
so let me give you a very simple
formulation
um of this class of locally adjustable
graph algorithms so this simple
formulation each node in the graph
starts off with some initial State and
then each node sends some function of
its initial state to his neighbor
so s0 is receiving some function of the
initial states of its immediate
Neighbors
now
zero has some predicate
and it counts the the set of strength
information from its neighbors that
satisfy the predicate so it counts the
number of this uh function of these
states that satisfy some predicate and
then updates is State according to that
number that satisfy their condition
and you can do this process in multiple
rounds so you update the state send the
function of the state and then count the
number of
results that satisfy your condition and
then update your state and so on so you
can produce you can repeat this
procedure via several rounds
and surprisingly maybe not surprisingly
um there's quite a few problems that
have algorithms that fall under this
paradigm and so we can turn all these
algorithms into private algorithms
so that that concludes my presentation
um happy to talk to any of you about
these problems or anything else
[Applause]
back in the 80s we had this thing called
the pram which was a parallel model with
uh random access memory and it was
deprecated because it really didn't pan
out in practice uh it sounds like you're
telling me that something like the P Ram
is back but maybe with a smaller degree
of parallelism than we had anticipated
in the past I mean is there is there a
fundamental difference other than that
so the pre-med model um correctly if I'm
wrong PM raw will generally assume some
p number of processors
um in the model and then your
complexities in terms of in terms of the
number of processors so here um for the
work depth model we actually get rid of
this parameter so the work work is this
total number of computational steps
depth is just your sequential longest
chain of sequential dependencies
so there's um no p in the the bounds and
generally we find that the work depth
model is a simpler formulation it's
easier to come up with a
theoretical guarantees in this bound and
getting rid of the processor doesn't the
processor parameter doesn't really
um affect the Practical performance as
much
like the distributed model with
differential privacy are you assuming
with the notes going to act in good
faith or uh yeah but it's not as strong
as option oh that could but actually be
a strong assumption so we are so the
question is uh whether the nodes are
acting in good faith when you're doing
the local model differential privacy yes
we're assuming that the low the nodes
are uh acting according to the protocol
um so actually I've gotten this problem
a few times before it is possible that
the nodes want to somehow perturb their
answers much to a much greater extent
than just adding some small amount of
noise
for whatever reason maybe they want to
mess up the statistics in the in the uh
in the aggregate data so that's
definitely something to consider
um as far as I know we have not
considered this um in the context of
graphs but I think we could this is
definitely something to consider for
future work
um
and just um as a side note as in these
Byzantine resilient algorithms we often
think that most users
performing good faith
so
perhaps not much of the statistic will
be messed up with it by these few users
we don't
okay
[Applause]